Caracas hace evaluación de daños el paso
de la onda Tropical 46 trajo intensas
lluvias con descargas eléctricas y
ráfagas de viento el martes a la capital
venezolana las autoridades iniciaron el
balance de los perjuicios ocasionados se
realiza evaluación de daños y análisis
de necesidades no se reportan personas
lesionadas la acción preventiva permitió
la evacuación de más de 50 familias en
situación de vulnerabilidad antes de las
precipitaciones y el riesgo de
deslizamientos pese a la presencia
Estatal los vecinos de la ladera un
barrio popular caraqueño denuncian la
mala planificación urbanística en el
sector que ya había sido víctima
anteriormente de otros derrumbes hay
casas que mandaron a desocupar y con el
transcurrir del tiempo pues volvieron a
habitar remodelaron reconstruyeron y se
siguieron habitando 12 años después se
ven las consecuencias de esas decisiones
los deslizamientos de tierra causaron
además el desbordamiento de varias
quebradas que inundaron vías arrastraron
vehículos y cortaron las comunicaciones
terrestres
una verdad que
mayorró bastante pues con la cuestión de
que me dicen que se había asustado
porque prácticamente ella nunca ha visto
esto y nosotros bueno Y si lo hemos
visto pero a verlo en carne propia No no
es distinto a que te lo cuenten a otras
personas pues las afectaciones en
Caracas se sumaron a las de otros 13
estados incluidas las de aragua en el
centro del país donde el pasado 17 de
octubre las intensas lluvias dejaron más
de 50 personas fallecidas